we're family
we always will be we don't need to see
each other
the harry potter 20th anniversary
reunion is here this is not a drill yeah
it's a almost out of body experience
being back here at livedon behind the
return to hogwarts special were intimate
moments between castmates an extremely
different leaves in studio rivals
sharing a trailer lessons learned and
complex choreo let's get back to
hogwarts
number one
okay it's time to achieve the tissues
it's really emotional to see everyone it
was amazing to see everyone again it's
it's been a long time filming the
special was a rewarding experience not
only professionally but personally as
well you see everyone's faces and it's
just lovely to be here and to share this
anniversary together number two
were there some time turners involved
with this special but it was like oh
just we're back here again with the
sword in dumbledore's office it very
much felt like that we all even though
it was 10 years ago since we finished
while it's been 20 years since the first
movie premiered you wouldn't have
guessed it on the reunion set it's
bizarre actually how uh how long it's
been since we've seen each other and how
short amount of time it took for us to
be uh
old chummy
back again so the smiles on everyone's
faces are pretty reminiscent of their
early days you know all the memories of
working here come flooding back and it
was yeah it was like it was last week
even jumping back into their roles was
simple enough kind of just walked
straight in and did my bit okay
without really looking around as if like
it was kind of back to work which is
weird ten years later number three
well we've sort of cool a setting like
this is perfect for making memories
most of us have sort of either snatched
little moments with each other before
we've gone off to do this that or the
other that was it yes he did us or um
had a little catch up now during lunch
this behind the scenes of emma and tom
together making more beautiful memories
got us right in the feels
number four
everybody get to places
orchestrating the choreo on the set was
quite the task both for the actual
dancing and for the filming crew that
very impressively maneuvered their way
around this magical set
number five
is this a reunion or straight up deja vu
there's also a couple of guys on the
crew who were on the crew when we were
filming so that's that's also cool
it wasn't just the cast who came to join
the festivities no one ever speaks
enough about the crew that made it as
well number six
and now they're all grown up for some it
was a bit harder to process it it's a
weird experience because you met them as
kids
not to me anyway now some of them are
married and they've got kids of their
own my memory of them is locked
it's sort of locked in but no matter how
much time has passed everyone was happy
to see where everyone was in their lives
this has been like a
family reunion literally patrick you
gotta remember when they started they
were about eight what do you think
you're doing down here i think the
oldest of them was eleven now they're
big grown-ups
with their own lives a family is a
family through and through people have
been asking me if it feels weird to see
the um
the family morning weasleys no it's not
it's 20 years ago and who are you
and they've all grown up as they should
and it'd be really weird if they were
still the same age these connections are
strong
number seven
the classic tale from rags to riches
leaves gin studio wasn't always such an
appealing attraction
it's really kind of strange when you
drive up because it was once it felt
like there was just a field but wait
why was it so different leaves totally
changed it's not what it was at all
because it was an old aircraft factory
you have to come back to
where it was actually taking place you
guys look great how are you this is
amazing albeit
it's been a bit more glamorous isn't it
now since when we were here before but
it's still really special the weasleys
weren't the only ones to feel that way
the other thing that struck me is how
much everything's changed i mean it
looks completely different to what it
looked like when we were here shooting
the whole studio is obviously much more
glossy than when we filmed on it number
eight
name a more iconic location duo it's
hard to put into words really getting to
visit two of the most special sets where
so many emotional moments took place
well there's nothing like it like being
in the great hall with everyone early
was just incredible while the studio
itself changed those sets are the real
deal i took a moment to just sort of
look around
the great hall
and sort of take it in and try and think
about the significance of it of being
back on there are you crying cause we're
crying it feels completely different
apart from when you get on set on the
studio tour because they were the
original set number nine
can the blacks and the malfoy's share a
trailer for the anniversary special
filming they did and we can't lie that's
one trailer we would have loved to hang
out in no bad blood here
number 10
back to hogwarts means back to school
right it's been a while since the crew
finished their time at school but being
back was a perfect time for a bit more
learning take more pictures
or write things down more looking back
it's it's quite nice it's kind of
documented as it is today we're talking
about things which happened which i
completely forgot about cherishing the
moment was a common theme just suddenly
thought for a moment hang on just recall
where you are right now
just take a moment i'm quite bad at
ever just having a moment and taking
things in around me being on set again
was also a reminder of just how far
they'd all come i think as as a teenager
i was often felt quite anxious on set
and felt self-conscious so to come here
and feel more grown up and more relaxed
it's lovely
i wish i'd felt this way i wish i felt
this relaxed when i when i was younger
actually
it also just feels really nice to come
back as an adult but with the maturity
and i suppose wisdom that you've gained
in 10 years number 11.
so this was pretty much a common theme
for everyone on set yes it was very
strange getting in the car and going
back to leeston studios that's something
you haven't done for a long time
that was a bit of a surreal start to the
day i suppose the studio was just
different enough that seeing it and
performing there was jarring it's
strange it's slightly disembodying
coming back um
because it's been for me probably over
how many years that's 11 years it feels
rather strange to be back here at least
then to be honest with you it's been a
while so a lot has changed and it's been
great seeing everyone
old familiar faces especially now that
their beloved set sees millions of
people touring through each year so much
of it is familiar but then also so much
of it is kind of slightly different
because obviously it's been turned it is
turned into this wonderful tour number
12.
who doesn't love a reunion while an
event like this would be overwhelming to
film and experience it was still a
mighty good time seeing everyone was
that was wild it was really cool i
really didn't know how it would feel i
felt quite overwhelmed this morning it
was really surreal in the in that it
didn't feel like it was it wasn't
unusual it was great and it was cool
i've just been really pleasantly
surprised by just actually yeah just
getting to relive it all the enjoyment
was pretty much radiating throughout
everyone in the studio but it was like
oh just we're back here again kind of
like watching your own kids grow up you
know
it was a very good 10 years how full is
everyone else's heart
yeah good times
the special itself and the behind the
scenes made for a reunion for the ages
so it's a it's very emotional
it was a long time ago and yet it's all
just incredibly familiar what was your
favorite part of the reunion
you